I'm scared because you made us do this
you brought this upon it if I didn't it
would take us like three hours so I
would be one game it is it yeah that's
longer than you think it took me a
couple days to complete also because I
had to figure shy think it took me about
four hours to finish like it took me a
couple days that's all wearing man yeah
I feel like that long as mean she's
coming I was gonna stare at something oh
yeah there's a key
I don't to move this H look at the H or
more I feel like that noise when she's
here oh Jesus oh god I hate that sound
sound look at the a-teams complete you
zoom in I am zoomed oh alright so
another thing if you don't freeze if she
murders you I don't actually know her
but that's what I relied on the quest
when I played it very sweaty then I mean
so you got the last part of it I think
so
and I don't do it please I must take it
you're too strong
no I'm Jana no it doesn't need to smoke
friends what are we sorry Kuno I don't
know a lot of you guys know I don't
remember I'm really gonna put so after
the fridge I remember there's a [ __ ]
hole in the wall but it's not there in a
couple more yeah no the one that goes
through the bathroom and you're like
supposed to look through it and [ __ ] we
need to get it to say hell is it an
abortion thing like she have an abortion
so the waiters it beautiful I don't
remember so look for a more text we need
to say hell is gonna be small way but I
really don't know I'm just gonna show up
I know she totally is associated with
that right here noise there right hard
to tell
I think that's fun [ __ ] me no no look at
something just look at something like
fixate on something well i yeah a minute
maybe that'll help you I don't actually
know what do you advise a meeting but I
feel like just look at look at something
like what I'm gonna give you background
huh just breathe got a dear
what would a dear do yeah cuz last time
she got us when we came to Facebook oh
yeah yeah because I think that that
noises her really I think so ok well I
hate that a lot it's not good news is
bad noise
okay go there's what no we do it wake up
side
stop nice nice well now I smash the
radio with my [ __ ] hand yep
action button where's the action to take
this [ __ ] wine bottle what do you
mean a conference match this is no real
video game no I want to take these wine
bottles and smash the radio mmm there
are guns in this there are a lot of five
we've been over this lady I know but I
just don't want to go in the toilet
the painting are you still thinking so I
slept a look at hello I think so oh I
think the letters disappear off this
wall oh yeah right and that's why
there's one elevator all right yeah all
right do you know if she can come once
yes that's good hello probably gonna say
are we done with this game oh that's
near what's new zero phases now it's
zero o'clock why is you're like shaking
sorry okay I think we just do one more
then we stop just you just get the end
what billion or it's so far from and
really yeah it's going well it's not
this long it's that it's like you know
it's a bunch of confusing stuff my heart
is up in my throat
it will take a little break it was a
little pee break no I have some big boy
running ready for it but give it here
you can walk through it won't walk
through it I believe in you
that looks [ __ ] oh look no you guys
this is interesting
oh no I've seen this yeah this shit's
[ __ ] [ __ ] no it's the same corridor
it's just all [ __ ] up and weird now oh
you're running
I forgot what to do during this do you
know oh it's our thing you supposed to
do
no I have no idea you just make me do I
enjoy yeah maybe I have to enjoy the
ride